[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the secrets easter eggs and
other things you might have missed while
watching the newly released jurassic
world dominion if you haven't watched
the movie yet press pause watch it and
then come back because we're going to
discuss some spoilers if you liked the
video be sure to leave us a like and
subscribe to the channel to not miss out
on any future content regarding your
favorite blockbuster movies without
further ado let's get started
perhaps not the most exquisite usage
presentation jurassic world dominion
commences with a useful and informative
news footage guide summarizing the
happenings of jurassic world and its
2018 sequel fallen kingdom the third
installment smartly regards what
occurred in jurassic park as a clearly
given both in and out of the film series
but one key character in dominion might
very well and conveniently flee fans
recognition lewis dodgson is presented
as the rich and powerful ceo of the
biology and genetics corporation biosin
and neither the personality nor the
corporation are creations of this movie
while [ __ ] obtained all of the
recognition both in jurassic park and
the lost world jurassic park as the
major scientific organization concerned
with realizing john hammond's fantasy
and delivering dinosaurs back from the
dead both biosin and dodgson have their
historical roots in the earliest michael
crichton book and the 1993 acclimation
for others who have overlooked the
background of that humorful jurassic
park incident we find a youthful dodgson
comply with mischievous engine worker
dennis nedry to organize for the
shipping of looted dinosaur fetuses in a
can of shaving cream nonetheless that
was pretty much the entire point of
biosit i.e corporate treason to close
the gap with technologically
sophisticated competing companies those
fetuses never apparently made it to
their final destination as nedry ends up
dead at the claws of a thirsty
dilophosaurus and his canister of
treasured fetuses gets misplaced in the
dirt however the long years have seemed
to have been exceedingly kind to dodgson
who rose to prominence in becoming ceo
and the key human villain in dominion
what a transformation dr henry wu played
by bd wong was yet another engine worker
who occurred in the same room as the
earliest attendees while hammond offered
them a tour of the place three decades
back then arrived jurassic world which
transformed him into one of the main
antagonists next to modern day efforts
to manipulate the dinosaur replicating
innovation he assisted in the first spot
dominion then opted to offer him a
full-fledged atonement plot line even
though it's a bit far-fetched one cannot
ignore the entertainment of viewing a
performer of wong's high caliber come
back for a somewhat stronger role in any
circumstance what dominion is doing with
his role offers some interesting
rollbacks and notifications to his
initial form back at the old park his
one big plotline was actually replying
to malcolm's suspicion that the
amusement park dinosaur landmarks would
not regenerate by themselves in the
outdoors of course engine
counterbalanced for this by trying to
make all reptiles female but engine's
predisposition for blending dinosaur dna
with other living creatures demonstrated
to be their ultimate downfall blue the
velociraptor has young of her own
pertaining to a wiser and far more
sourful woo and dominion when questioned
if biosin has been using dna splicing
methods he makes a sardonic comment it
seems that a lesson has been learned
remember that can of shaving cream
referenced it returns in dominion like a
thief in the night unexpectedly in the
movie dodge center is apprentice ramsay
trying to escape to the ceo's
underground facility since everything
beyond biosin head office falls to
pieces we kept glimpses of the same can
of shaving cream installed in a corner
in this vast collection of artifacts and
memorabilia how did it get out of the
filth and were most of its fetuses still
intact dominion has far more urgent
matters than trying to explain away
those troublesome quibbles but fans can
absolutely guarantee that this specific
can will be seen at least once more the
upcoming fifth season of the continuing
camp cretaceous cartoon series will grab
up this discussion in a bigger direction
till then the can is an enjoyable
connection that demonstrates how even
trivial things from the original movie
are still striking a chord after all of
these years down the line
did you actually think we had already
had enough of one of jurassic park's
most magnificent and potentially lethal
inclusions we hoped in advance that the
dilophosaurus would come back for the
very first time since jurassic park but
the role which these deadly carnivores
represent in dominion is a bit of a
throwback to the original movie but
before a crash course in scientific
knowledge apart from velociraptors
dilophosaurus is perhaps the most
egregious illustration of the film's
overestimating a genuine neolithic beast
for maximum effect we have no scientific
proof that these dinosaurs also had neck
fluff or vomit bright poison at their
scavengers but it appears to work in
universe because engines screwed with
their genetic material in any scenario
the dinosaur life form is best
recognized for providing nedry to a
horrific and quite well-deserved final
moment trying to blind him with its
poison after a horrendously odd game of
grab in dominion their humorous little
routine of handing out justice is back
with a desire for revenge when a flock
traps the evil dodgson and sends him out
in the same manner as nedry years ago we
have to start believing that the old
engine worker would be enthralled by the
way he and his buddy dodgson dropped
dead
dr grant and dr malcolm had not really
appreciated one another owing to their
starkly different personas the way they
followed their professional careers and
their high regard for a certain dr
sattler they found a way to put apart
their disparities and sustain the
happenings of jurassic park but their
competition is reawakened in dominion
amidst his selfish decision to enter
biosin as their registered chaotician
trying to deliver disparaging sermons
about humanity's spot in the food supply
chain and trying to make money with his
latest book malcolm preserves his spirit
when he facilitates his old buddies in
busting into biosin and finding the
incriminating documents they need but
malcolm's genuine repayment arrives when
the team is threatened by the
intimidating giganotosaurus the world's
biggest meat-eating killer to take a
stroll on solid ground the vibrant
scientist does seem to have a courageous
track record first rescuing the day by
scooping up a firework to divert the
t-rex from its invasion that does not go
very well on the contrary he eventually
gets his time to flourish when he tends
to make a spontaneous firework in
dominion and satisfactorily retaliates
to the giganotosaurus providing the
others beneficial time to reach
protection same hacks but better
outcomes for such an old dog
a strange-looking artifact in a nearly
oval-like structure is shown in the
surroundings throughout grant sattler's
reunion of sorts in the latter's
excavation location shelter that is a
raptor reverberating compartment which
we have seen in jurassic park 3 and into
whom grant managed to blow air to try
and replicate the distinct and unique
whale of the velociraptors grant still
behaves like a residing fossil and
envelops himself with what he believes
ideal even years down the line some
things are timeless
when we first encounter owen grady
played by chris pratt he is in the
middle of maneuvering a parasaurophilus
out of the sierra nevada woods to help
bring them to protection as awesome as
this appearance is this isn't the first
time that people have repeatedly tried
the very same trick with much the same
species of dinosaur in the lost world
jurassic park [ __ ] militias invade isla
sorna and strive to curl up dinosaurs in
a comparable pattern in order to develop
a new park back on the continent in san
diego they even have the same string
technique as grady however for really
distinct causes
steven spielberg is a child of divorced
parents and that is the reason divorce
is a constant motif in his films and it
is a constant theme all through the
jurassic park film series even after
spielberg abandoned the driving seat of
directors after the lost world dr ian
malcolm tells in the earliest jurassic
park that he's really on the high alert
for the upcoming future ex mrs malcolm
describing that he has three children
from multiple partners the eventual
divorce of dr john hammond's child seems
to be more central to the plot this is
why he welcomes lex and tim to the isle
in the first spot to shift their
attention aside from their mom and dad's
hurtful court case
in jurassic park 3 paul and amanda kirby
deceived dr grant into accepting them to
isla sorna by acting as a prosperous
pair enthusiastic to buy shares in his
career they are in fact eric's separated
parents who mysteriously disappeared
while paragliding with his mom's
boyfriend the narrative of jurassic
world is reprocessed by placing claire
in command of her sister's sons zac and
grey while their mom and dad hammer out
the details of their breakup which tends
to put a strain on the children
regardless of everyone's value and
efforts to safeguard them from this
correspondingly dominion cites three
more divorce cases ellie is no longer
with her husband however she has two
adult children with him and ian already
has five ex-wives
among the many box office hits directed
by steven spielberg are the indiana
jones films wherein harrison ford's
indie has never been seen without his
hat in indiana jones and the temple of
doom there is a scenario where the hat
seems to be out of range he starts
rolling further against logic to scoop
it up just in time apparently the
striking similarities between indiana
jones and dr alan grant are clearly
evident the first is an archaeologist
and the second is a paleontologist
they're all tiny bit annoyed so they
both try to avoid devotion as much as
probable dr grant not only
circumnavigates passageways with a lit
flame but he also does have his very own
hat occasion while attempting to escape
dimetrodons in the waterlogged amber
mining sites with ellie and maisie this
is unquestionably a wonderful tribute to
spielberg and indiana jones from yet
another murky but sneakily warm-hearted
traveler
i read your book alan grant his
condition to constantly hearing younger
audiences of his mention the very same
thing to him first there was tim in
jurassic park john hammond's borderline
obsessive grandchild who loved and
respected grant's feet all the time now
it is owen grady himself though he
actually admitted he only did listen to
the audiobook version the two
protagonists share astonishing little
time on screen in dominion but grant has
always had several fans around the world
that's it for today have you noticed
some of these secrets already did we
leave out another secret or easter egg
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to leave us a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe for more
content on the biggest upcoming
blockbusters until next time
[Music]
you